Dove tried to haggle with this dude okay  absolutely brutalized him okay the dude  comes running back with the 20 American  bill that Doug paid with well this  doesn't work  he's holding up to the light-ish dove  just starts to freak out if anyone have  200 on them they'll take this grabs a  200 Moroccan And Trades it Alex  immediately realizes yo that's not the  20 you paid for they got counterfeit 20s  there and they're coming back and  flipping them  twice  double for his thing he's a horrible  negotiator that's what you get you got  body bro bent over rinsed out oh no I  got some Berber boner powder if you want  to get that again  stupid fake story